e me permita começar essa apresentação
de um outro lugar isso porque antes de
ser influenciador fotógrafo e escritor
Eu sou um homem de Candomblé e quando eu
nasci nessa tradição eu recebi o nome de
Allah o me o meu nome africano é
composto por três palavras Alá aí ó e o
me o que quer dizer numa tradução breve
aquele que é protegido pelo Senhor da
criação e traz alegria das águas Esse é
o nome que me ajudou a recuperar o meu
sentido de humanidade é esse nome que me
lembra todos os dias que a minha
história é anterior ao processo de
escravização em todas as tradições
africanas o nome de sobre o Nosso
propósito sobre os feitos da nossa
família sobre do que somos feitos
e viemos para esse lugar se pergunte o
que que o seu nome diz sobre você o que
o nome da sua cidade de origem de sobre
a sua comunidade o Candomblé que me
constituiu foi elaborado a partir da
herança ancestral yorubá uma das
civilizações mais sofisticadas mais
importantes do continente africano que
foi fundada a partir de lei fé e Leifert
é o nosso berço civilizatório e para mim
é muito importante entender que e Lei fé
numa tradução literal por exemplo eu
posso chamar de casa do amor que potente
e saber que o povo de onde eu acendo
parte de um lugar elaborado a partir do
amor para essa cultura para mim a
tradição O amor é um valor civilizatório
entenda isso eu não sou de uma família
biológica tradicionalmente do Candomblé
inclusive foi no meu trabalho que eu
compreende todos os processos de
distanciamento que o racismo provocou
e para que eu e mais uma série de outras
pessoas não tivesse acesso às potências
das tradições afro-brasileiras que foram
elaboradas no Brasil inclusive e foi no
meu trabalho que o compreendi o quanto
que o racismo elaborou para nos
distanciar das nossas tradições
demonizando e marginalizando o símbolos
a fé as divindades e o povo de Candomblé
e É nesse reencontro que eu entendo
também que uma das minhas formas de
contribuir para a valorização desse
legado seria utilizar da fotografia e da
escrita para revelar borar esses
imaginários para reconstruir as
narrativas de uma forma que humanize não
só esses territórios mas também cada
pessoa que participa desse processo foi
a fotografia que me deu condição de
propor um diálogo em que a sociedade
possa humanizar mais a imagem das
pessoas que foram violentadas nesse
processo
é porque o candomblé é sobretudo um
lugar de dar colo um lugar de acolher o
canal não é sobre potencializar as
nossas existências isso é muito
importante lembra disso o Tumblr nasceu
para dar colo e acolher e por favor
reconheça a sério que o mal foi Sagaz
reconheço a sério com mal foi Sagaz é
uma das frases que mais me toca no disco
Amarelo Adormecida um dos grandes
intelectuais do nosso tempo eu uso essa
frase para denunciar sobre o que se
trata o processo de escravização no
Brasil um dos maiores crimes da
humanidade não foram só mais de cinco
milhões de Corpos pretos sequestradas e
reduzidos a função de objetos para as
mais variadas atrocidades nesse lugar é
também sobre um processo que se
instauram nesse país por quase
quatrocentos anos que cravou feridas que
ainda latejam em cada pessoa preta nesse
país reconheço as é
um copo e Sagaz e destroçou a identidade
EA subjetividade de cada um de nós e
ainda que a nossa história não tenha
começado na escravidão ela foi
brutalmente interrompida por ela e a
gente precisa falar sobre isso a Bell
hooks uma importante Pensador
afro-americana denuncia no texto vivendo
de amor como o processo de escravização
impactou na forma de pessoas pretas amar
ela ainda conta que naquele contexto a
não criação de vincular uma estratégia
de sobrevivência do nosso povo mas essa
prática sequela o nosso povo e ainda
atravessa as relações em nossa
comunidade e com os nossos espelhos
lembra de mal com ex perguntando quem te
ensinou a odiar o teu cabelo o teu nariz
a tua boca aquilo também era um alerta
para que a gente compreendesse o quanto
de Alto ódio e de desamor esse processo
implantou nas nossas identidades para
nos aprisionar
se lembrar quem são os responsáveis pela
nossa tragédia mas também é urgente que
a gente lembre quem nós somos antes de
tudo isso é só uma sociedade que nos
determinou ódio como a única experiência
afetiva se pergunte por que nos deram
ódio nos ensinaram a partir do ódio e
aqui estamos cada vez mais distanciados
de nós mesmo e é por isso que eu me
dedico e convido para que a gente
Elabore a partir da revolução do Amor
esse afeto é o único caminho para
interromper todo o processo de
desumanização que mata e sequestra a
nossa subjetividade ao longo de toda uma
história produzida em violências e isso
é sobre reconstruir as nossas relações
isso é sobre relator ar as nossas
identidades a partir do amor nós temos
um compromisso um ancestral de retomar o
rumo das nossas histórias e reconstruir
a partir de nós mesmo
o convite para gente recriar e
fortalecer as nossas experiências de
afeto é urgente que a gente assuma o
compromisso de ensinar às nossas
crianças a potência de amarrar o que
elas veem no espelho e no brilho dos
olhos escuros de cada um dos seus iguais
nós podemos ensinar sobre o amor
ensinando sobre as belezas de cada fio
crespo que guarda a consciência de cada
um de nós e tudo isso a partir do amor é
o amor entre a gente que nos salvará e
ajudar a erradicar as violências
restauradas o nosso espaço pela ação do
racismo e da são patriarcal eu tô
falando que é o amor aos nossos e as
nossas idosas as crianças negras as
pessoas trans esse amor que humaniza
todas as nossas identidades só esse amor
pode nos salvar o amor que potencializa
a existência de mulheres negras gestoras
as nossas transformações o amor
e elabora o acolhimento impede que
homens pretos em fuga dos seus problemas
não encontre apenas as ruas as drogas o
cárcere como a única solução de fuga é o
amor e Essência em forma genuína que
humaniza a pessoas pretas abraçando cada
curva das nossas contradições e
aquilombando para que a gente possa
proteger e impulsionar a nossa revolução
e é nisso que eu acredito na realização
do sentido de humanidade que a
escravização negou aos nossos ancestrais
quando ele se pediram o direito de amar
eu quero ser e te convido a ser a
realização dos Sonhos dos nossos mais
velhos que não puderam amar Esse é o meu
convite é hora de voltar para casa hoje
não haverá revolução sem que antes a
gente retorne para o berço da nossa
história e compreenda no Legado de quem
chegou antes a potência que é amar
Afinal nós somos frutos de lei fé nós
somos os herdeiros da casa do amor muito
obrigado axé
E aí